thank you surf shark VPN for sponsoring
this video
it sounds like a Shakira song alright
today on the cruise report welcome to
the button a speed dating show when the
button lights up red either player may
press it and swap out their date for a
new person you know what this is what
robot war we thought robots were gonna
sound like in the 90s I'm going to stick
in you like this is what we think so to
have a video in 2020 is absurd and for
no reason for no reason oh good reason
you couldn't have just someone say that
you could have literally had any voice
if two people can last on a date for ten
minutes they win an all-expenses-paid
second date and the guys halfway in
there like he's ready she's trying to do
me like that he just went in saying I'm
gonna eliminate the first girl no matter
what go check our reaction is great it's
wonderful oh you like to dance what kind
of dancing musics good finding out
you're being rejected after someone
kicks you out he's having a stupid robot
being sorry you have been eliminated
I don't need you to say nothing I know
I'm mad for this girl I'm mad for who
invited this robot the button no I did
just it's a feeling I just wasn't
feeling it
how's it going what's your name Andrew
Caitlin nice to meet you nice to meet
you what do you like to do for fun I
love to dance I'm totally a
self-proclaimed cat lady so I spent a
lot of times with my cats I like to read
I talk a lot that's her dope I like to
read that's her dope cancer go
[Music]
I'm a self-proclaimed cat lady why are
you leading with I don't shave my
poom-poom yeah you said you were cat
lady I just assumed yeah you probably
smell that cat litter at home you ever
been to a girl's place when it smells
like cat litter I'm gonna tell you what
happened bro I went to a few girls house
and I kept smelling to see and I'm like
you're are these coordinating these
smells because it started up excited
know what a cat litter smell yeah why
did you do that just wasn't attracted to
her hi how are you I'm good I'm good
nice to meet you I'm backup nice to meet
you Becca why do you guys do for a
living I'm a bartender I sell software
sapphire super nerdy [ __ ] I drove her
tattoo that's still one dollar got the
flower of life yeah do you have an age
preference yeah probably 25 to 30 how
old are you I'm 40 okay
I'm I'm a feel okay no offense but I
also like don't fall into your thing
no that's good no it's cool yeah so it
sounded less unless like a robot and
more and more like Marge Simpson it just
sounds like it's been smoking for a long
time my margins sister yes I did you
eliminate and because he's oh oh hello
good how are you very good
my name is Becca what's your name well
gun Republicans ah that's interesting
I don't wait are you registered to vote
no I'm actually not from here oh okay
who is hold up this robot sees the first
girl on stage and that's the first
question if you don't get the [ __ ] the
button they can't move you haven't
pressed your button yet do you want to
[Music]
okay cool
is that an Apple watch oh good question
how much TV
oh [ __ ] I'm a budget analyst you make my
money hey that sounds like a real adult
job oh yeah I have a bartender that's
what's up
[Music]
she was thinking it in her head she was
speaking eliminate you before you
eliminate me you know what it is when
someone it's like speaking but
hesitantly it like when you're into
somebody it's a free-flowing
conversation goes back and forth you're
laughing you're engaging it's not there
you could see everything is tense here I
don't know he was cool and I liked
talking to him but like I just know not
really my type okay I don't find him
attractive I'm back
how are you I'm fantastic good listen
listen will you sit you're really
controlling the but it's interrupting
srews yeah
I don't it's kind of it's giving you
prompts and now I don't remember what I
was saying doing my best
this is really hard what are some of
your turn offs like instantly like you
know if a girl drinks like plastic water
bottles like the non reusable ones oh so
you're like environment-friendly yeah
anything food soiled like food soiled
paper like food so napkins Authority the
compost any food waste like watermelon
Ryan's see the prom isn't that he's food
and waste she's too enthusiastic about
it you know I mean like about that
nobody gives a [ __ ] about yeah but in
the dating thing we're trying to I feel
like a lot of people like that one meet
on a date and I think that's also why a
lot of people feel but she's not picking
up on the fact that she doesn't actually
care no she doesn't
you know I mean you can see him rattle
off this information and she's not
engaging with it give you an example I
love anime manga someone asked me about
anime and manga and I started rattling
off and the other person who's clearly
uninterested I wouldn't keep going
that make sense yeah there's something
about the way he's saying stuff to me
that just saw her face why shouldn't you
why shouldn't someone date me yeah I
mean I have a lot of Legos I got my
house tell me more about Legos a little
like plastic building know what they are
but why do you have because they're fun
you just like bias it and put it
together and then you have like a TIE
fighter associates you know what you
watch Star Wars ah and the Mandalorian
takes place like chronologically after
Yoda's death in the southwest timeline
you know what being tortured into is not
the problem just understand how to
connect with the other person with what
you're doing I wouldn't be like you know
teacher onizuka bringing his first
person to class was to be able to change
her life around she'd be like what are
you talking about
but I would say is like enemy for me was
some of my bonded with as a kid and so
just of my like I'm sure you like
cartoons yourself or maybe some of you
watch as a kid you find a way to have
that conversation on the evil playing
field you don't go into astrophysics
like what is you doing are you a
scientist the square root of Pythagoras
movie is mainly actually Galileo Galilei
Galilei so what do you advented with
that sounds like a
I'll get it I'll get it
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
and that's the but my dear a VPN is a
virtual private network so privacy
protection tools which guarantees our
online safety so when you're surfing the
web and you want to protect your
passwords your videos your photos all
your encrypted data and you want to make
sure that nobody steals it
that's where VPN comes in and keeps all
of your stuff safe look guys I know
times are tough you won't be bored
you're gonna want to do things and so
there might be TV shows you want to
watch and those TV shows might get
blocked because your IP address you
didn't choose where you were born you
didn't choose well you kind of chose
where you live but anyways if you want
to be able to watch these TV shows you
shouldnt have to move to do so use a VPN
bypass that and that's where surf chart
comes in now because you're one of our
fans I'm saying about to hook you up
eighty-three percent off plus one month
for free that's a good deal you paint
seventeen percent you just paint the
Texas well you're not literally but I'm
just saying you know get seventeen
anyways it's not that important try it
out they got a 30-day money-back
guarantee but if you want to access all
these TV shows a whole bunch of good
stuff is gonna come up because
you know we're gonna be bored during
this pandemic jump on it
thank you a surf shark we really
appreciate the support she said you just
know so much about it it's not the fight
that he knows too much about it but
she's trying to say is like you left me
during this conversation that's all we
did we're having the conversation you
went over there so again guys being
being nerdy is not a problem in fact
being nerdy today's is it's hugely in
all right and take it from your resident
anime nerd read that get every day I
have a girl I'll still read it in front
of a girl don't give up but I also
understand that when I'm on a date I'm
not gonna drown her in anime facts
started talking about the Mandalorian I
watched it but I'm like bro you do it
too much you're doing the most oh he was
so happy
what bothered me is not the Finity just
rattle off he was very unaware about how
he came across I mean I guess it's not a
deal breaker if you like know a lot
about Star Wars but like right so you're
the one on the street huh I'm not trying
it's not I'm just playing with you
what's your name okay sweetie you know
the same hike I bet you she strikes me
as a type of girl who likes bigger
strong you don't have to talk about you
that's what she strikes me she probably
he's getting tossed around the room boss
he's like flying through the air say
[Applause]
spitballing here I'm not saying I'm just
guessing I pretty much only smoke indica
sativa kind of freaks me out elope yeah
[Music]
yeah weave is bumping
you're a bad third wheel you're not
adding anything good to this thing you
know what makes me think this person
makes me think of like know that like
really white dad who wants to be like
yeah hey Simon
personality with the questions maybe you
know maybe you guys want some pop okay
I'll be right back oh now watch me is
something I heard that you like women
sick come on
points so you guys are you I do I'm
definitely not that don't see you notice
when I walked in I don't know I just
wasn't my type he wasn't my type I feel
really bad hitting the button it's
making me feel so bad know if a girl
looks at you and she looks a like oh
yeah if they tuck their chin in like
this ruff it's a tail cat fat girl lets
you see her double chin that because she
she's trying to get a better look better
and men do the same thing when Nancy a
good girl but oh you know this same
thing nice to meet you nice to meet you
name is Becca it's nice to meet you back
here how are you doing today I'm good
I'm 22 26
[Laughter]
humor like a stealth bomber
why didn't you eliminate she was too
young you get some years put on your
life 23 to 26 I'm Chris I'm hazel hazel
nice to meet you meet you know gosh
already No No maybe I mean it's pretty
Oh
you can't look at the button like that
[ __ ] yeah I see what you did I see what
he did I see what you're saying
he's already just a good no no maybe
I mean it's pretty pretty easy I think
were you nervous back there I was a
little nervous it's weird yeah come on
mad at him for that one goes off we're
daisies rule she was nervous about game
lemonade they didn't seem like they were
talking like yeah I just don't like it
as these people are walking off and they
know they've been eliminated some dumb
robot in lemonade oh man it's like I
know I'm in my car comes on your radio
no you don't understand
you've been I'm trying to plug in my
iphone can I just do my thing no you're
eliminated I'm going home do you know
the name of our channel cut you've been
cut why did you eliminate she just
wasn't my type Wow
I'm not sure I like this why I just feel
so bad it's not often that guys have to
like reject girls a girl's got to do all
the time it's a weird world we live in
Emma it's nice to meet you Emma are you
from Seattle I'm actually from Maine
yes yeah road trip out here this summer
oh yeah oh yeah never been to the west
coast that's a [ __ ] long road trip was
it worth it so worth it yeah that's like
brunettes and Deborah how nice what
about you tall dark and handsome he was
going on you bring a wingman well I mean
that's just like what I grew up with so
maybe it's a nostalgia but you know
keeps me a kid at heart if he's smart
he's not gonna answer Internet I
personally would never answer that I
would flip it on her toe you would ask
her no I'd be like I'm not gonna answer
that and I don't think you should hmm
true protecting both wounds or true I
don't think there's a good answer to
that question too low of a number sound
suspicious too high of a number some
suspicious you knowing the exact set
number sounds suspicious you not knowing
the number something either loose loose
loose loose coupling you're not winning
this one yeah so I would never answer
that question but now so I don't think
it matters and don't but I mean I would
never even answer that question because
if you're never gonna win on that I've
seen couples who asked him selves that
question in front of other people like
they've been dating for a year and a
half and the guy will like let's say
saying like an outrageously high number
and the girl didn't know and I could
tell the girl was super bothered by what
she discovered because now she's
comparing herself even though everything
was good all of a sudden there is no
suspicion of none and then you put that
doubt that wet so you compare me to how
many yo
ya know if nobody's business here's what
I'll tell you the number of people
someone has slept with is not a good
indication of their character is like
that the people that they chose to sleep
with is meaning if you have had five
relationships and there was only people
that you slept with and all five of
those people were bad people
that tells me way more about you that if
you start enumerated 60 people that you
slept with and they're all decent human
beings do you do what I'm saying
it's not about how many people are with
it's about who you're with and what
those experiences like unless you want
to talk tell me I gotta tell your story
so what happened and you tell me Willie
that that's not looking to find out but
generally when women ask you for your
number yeah it's cuz they want to tell
you what they want they want an arene
your number so the guy joined on my
number and then afterwards I don't we
say no but let's say if I were to tell
like yeah I want to hear a number
afterwards okay so what's your number I
told you mine you have to tell me yours
so that's why they do it often time I'm
not gonna answer
[Music]
III don't know and I'm gonna answer the
question because I do want to stay on
this date so it's like okay I throw all
my cards it's around like 60 okay he's
good for him that's what you give or
take okay now it's your turn let's see I
think around like 20 okay yeah for sure
it's going pretty well
you two are cute together well thank you
I think you're cute I think you're super
huge Fisher
I couldn't tell
yes compliment each other more anyway we
already know I'm not watching anymore we
have that was a couple of frames ago he
has already been done it's all been done
you know this is like it's like whenever
when think try to come up with like new
concepts for series and I'm like bro we
just like watching two strangers talk to
each other on a blind team
you don't have to do all this crazy
stuff where you do robots in Chadha why
I'll sign up for this stuff it's just
like some of y'all like you were asking
for it and I hope they paid you guys and
I hope it was worth it to get rejected
in front of millions of people that's
awkward that's rough if your average or
ugly don't even bother because like
we're being honest mostly people
pressing the button on the basis of
looks she wasn't my type I wasn't
feeling it I know wouldn't work out
together what based off looking at her
cuz they're just judging people on their
looks do people really feel bad about
rejecting people no I'm not talking
about being liveing we yes we feed them
yeah yeah you don't know why because
everyone thinks of themselves as a good
person true so to make someone sad
doesn't make normal people feel good
unless you're so so bad yeah when you
reject someone on TV you don't care
because they're not face to face you
don't see the ramifications of what
you're doing and the person doesn't
actually get to talk to each other yeah
but it was we're know what your thoughts
were what did you guys think about this
video did you guys feel uncomfortable if
so let us know why
[Music]